a last gasp defense against a new type
of bombardment
Kamikaze drones
and waves of missiles Russia Unleashed a
barrage on civilian life across Ukraine
but there was another Target energy
infrastructure this a missile strike
near a thermal plant in South cave
power plants across the country have
been hit over the last 10 days it is an
escalation of a war that's been fought
all along throughout the wider conflict
the energy War
zapparigia on the edge of areas annexed
by Russia has been at the heart of it
Russia wants to power its newly claimed
territory there Ukraine can't afford to
lose the largest nuclear plant in Europe
which once supplied 20 percent of its
electricity
the ongoing stalemate is perilous and
has prompted fears of an atomic disaster
on the scale of Chernobyl or Fukushima a
nuclear power plant in the middle of an
active war zone is obviously caused for
concern but we think there's something
more going on here the Sky News data and
forensics unit has used satellite
imagery and videos filmed on the ground
posted to social media to try and
understand the pattern
the zapparigia nuclear power plant is
located on the danipa river in the south
of Ukraine both sides have blamed each
other for attacks around the plant it's
impossible to verify those claims but we
can build up a detailed picture of the
fighting
the nuclear reactors at the center of
those fears of an accident have not been
hit but the infrastructure around them
including the fuel cooling system and
processing buildings have
on August the 24th satellite images
showed large amounts of smoke coming
from areas outside the nuclear plant
after sustained shelling
this is thermal satellite imagery and
our analysis shows that this is the fire
where the smoke is coming from
but then we need one more crucial bit of
context because this is right where the
power lines that run from the plant and
Supply Ukraine with energy run
let's look at another attack this is
part of the system used to call spent
nuclear fuel
these images on the left hand side were
posted to a Russian social media account
on September the 20th
it shows part of the cooling system
destroyed and they match up with the
satellite imagery
nearby is the fuel processing building
the satellite image shows damage to its
roof on the right hand side we've
highlighted it in this box here but this
picture from the ground posted to the
social media platform telegram on August
the 29th shows the damage much more
clearly
so far we've been talking about physical
infrastructure but Ukrainian civilians
have been working at the site throughout
the conflict risking their lives on
August the 22nd an engineer at the plant
of vladislav Mitten was killed after a
taxi he was traveling to work in was hit
by artillery
from what we can tell vladislav was
traveling up this road it has a series
of pipes running across it which we've
identified in white here
we can look at Google Earth and match it
with a video taken by another person
driving to the scene after the attack
and we can see the same pipes we
identified earlier
watch out on the right we've blurred the
image but slumped over the wheel of the
car it's the taxi driver the vehicle
riddled with shrapnel at this point
vladislav had been taken to hospital
authorities confirmed he died there
later
so those were all the attacks now the
question is why and we've seen the
nuclear actors themselves haven't been
in much danger we think there's a
different strategy at Play
once we've done the work verifying and
geolocating all of these attacks one by
one you can start to see a pattern
emerge if we look here we can see all
the power lines coming out of the power
station by attacking the areas we've
spoken about it cripples the station's
ability to export power out to the rest
of the country and onwards to Europe
we've got to be careful with Zappa reach
though because there are historically
that's proprieted most of the power the
electrical power for the island of
Crimea as well and as soon as the
Russians annexed that in 2014 the
ukrainians cut them off the grid and
therefore for uh for all sorts of
reasons Russia would want to get that
power re-established and control that
power for Crimea other plants have been
targeted across the country including
the South Ukraine nuclear power plant
CCTV captured the nighttime strike which
weaved geolocated and we know that
missiles have flown over the plant this
one shown on the left hand side of the
screen just one example showing the
action in the area
that's the situation in the South but
other places in the country have also
been targeted let's move Northeast now
to kharkiv where this plan was attacked
Ukrainian officials said can't give Tech
5 the country's second biggest thermal
power plant had been hit in a Russian
strike firefighters are seen trying to
contain the fire and the attacks on
Ukraine's energy infrastructure like
this one in leviv in the west of the
country increase the pressure on
European nations including the UK as
they struggle with soaring Energy prices
the West will have to overcome this I'm
not sure electricity is the big big
issue it's heating people's homes and
the oil and gas that's required to do
that but undoubtedly the power station
in the longer term for Ukraine it's such
a let's say as you said it's 20 of the
power for the nation they will want to
get that back as the front line shifts
again the battle for zapparigia nuclear
power plant will only become more
intense
two conflicts the ground war and the
energy war and they are fighting for
every inch Tom Cheshire Sky News